the difference in Direction between the
Bayonetta Trilogy and the newest entry
in the series Bayonetta origin cereza
and the lost demon is impossible to
ignore in place of the self-assured
dominatrix we know and love is a timid
young girl who is far more comfortable
clutching a stuffed animal than she has
a pistol instead of large-scale
action-packed set pieces in the mainline
series unapologetically over-the-top
style we are treated to enchanted
forests and well-worn book pages adorned
with soft illustrations as such the
first few hours I spent with Bayonetta
Origins were filled with complete and
utter confusion I couldn't find the
connection between Bayonetta Origins and
the Bayonetta trilogy but thankfully the
team behind Bayonetta Origins could
Bayonetta Origins is an achievement both
within the Bayonetta series and games as
a whole it is proof the rules and
limitations placed on certain big budget
series are made to be broken especially
when you can do it with this much
creativity the Charming Adventure
Puzzler is also just delightful to play
and is far more than what it appears to
be on the surface as its story unfolds
it slowly builds into a recognizably
Bayonetta game one filled with
excitement darkness subversions and
feminine Liberation all while
maintaining an identity that's all its
own all this combined with a touching
tale of companionship and maternal love
that may or may not have made me cry a
lot makes her a game I urge you not to
overlook
foreign
[Music]
steps into the souped up shoes of
Bayonetta Origins is best described as a
coming of half-lumen sage story after
witnessing her mother's imprisonment due
to a forbidden romance with cereza's
Father the young girl is forced to seek
Refuge under the tutelage of a powerful
witch who lives on the outskirts of the
Forbidden Avalon Forest her teacher is
firm yet kind clearly intended to show
in part where bayonetta's cool demeanor
comes from but is often frustrated by
cereza's cowardice as such when a spirit
visits cereza and tells her the courage
she needs to become a proper witch and
rescue her mother lies deep in Avalon
the young witch quickly sets off in
search of it however there is a reason
Avalon Forest is forbidden large
portions of the forest have become
corrupted by malevolent fairies creating
Rifts that transport cereza to a bright
yet Sinister Dimension that looks more
or less like a hellscape straight out of
Monica Magicka while cereza isn't yet
equipped to take them on herself she
manages to round up some help in the
form of a demon she summons forth and
attaches to her cherished stuffed animal
Cheshire
don't worry I'll send you home
once I figure out how
I'm on my way to get a fantastic power
with that
with that you back should be a piece of
cake
the dynamic between series and Cheshire
then becomes not only the heartbeat of
Bayonetta origin story but the Crux of
its ingenious and delightfully fun
gameplay as well in Bayonetta Origins
you control both cereza and Cheshire
simultaneously with all of cereza's
controls assigned to the left joy-con
while all of cheshires are located on
the right
similar to any Haze light production
such as it takes two away out Brothers A
Tale of Two Sons the game is filled with
asymmetrical puzzles that require you to
explore your environment and use both
characters various talents to progress
for cereza this means using her magic to
bring helpful plants to life and stun
enemies as well as taking advantage of
her small framed across Vines Cheshire
on the other hand utilizes his brute
strength large size and elemental powers
he slowly unlocks to blaze ahead when
Cheshire can't cross a particular area
cereza steps in to create a path and
when cereza can't reach a high ledge
Cheshire allows himself to shrink down
into his stuffed animal form and be
tossed to the once inaccessible ledge
while not particularly difficult the
puzzles are well balanced interesting
and continuously build in small ways
properly preparing you for what line of
thinking the next obstacle might require
with this style of gameplay and the
nature of the controls there are a few
instances where I felt my wires get
crossed and I'd accidentally moved
Cheshire rather than cereza or vice
versa thankfully the consequences for
this are never dire and I found that as
I progressed these Mix-Ups happened less
and less considering all the actions you
can take as both members of this demonic
Duo the mapping is actually incredibly
intuitive and makes for the smoothest
and most exciting single button combat
I've seen executed in a game a large
reason why the game's combat is as
satisfying as it is is because of how
the puzzle aspect of the game also
extends to your encounters the vast
majority of enemies you square off
against require either cheshire's
Elemental abilities or ceres's magic
which takes shape as a sort of small
scale rhythm game to make them
vulnerable to attack this makes battles
and particularly the challenging turn
nanog stages which feels somewhat like
more combat-oriented breath of the wild
shrines require quick thinking and
careful coordination on the player's
part to make matters more exciting as
enemy types and the number of waves you
face off against expand so does the
feeling that you are truly playing an
action-packed Bayonetta game albeit a
very different one from what's come
before that said players might find that
Bayonetta Origins combat is where the
aforementioned crossed wires problem
tends to happen the most and it's where
it's the most frustrating while I found
the technique of frequently recalling
Cheshire in order to narrow my attention
to one character to control the bulk of
the time you need to be playing as both
which can result in some fairly
inelegant gameplay additionally this
complexity can feel a bit at odd with
the light-hearted and inviting nature of
the game though the game's story and
World make this an easy recommendation
for younger players the controls could
make the experience a bit of a struggle
[Music]
foreign
while I won't delve into spoiler
territory because frankly the game's
story and callbacks are too special to
want to ruin them it impressed me how
much Bayonetta Origins begins in one
place and lightly dances towards another
we are more familiar with thankfully
however Crossing this bridge does not
correlate to a change in tone I was a
bit worried that as there is a grew more
competent and more confident the game
might Force sexuality on the young girl
and Rob the game of its child like
Wonder I can now assure you it does not
but rather allow cereza to be a child
discovering her strength and confidence
in different ways before delving into
the world of Guns and Leather and aside
from the sheer inappropriateness that
would have accompanied that tonal shift
Bayonetta Origins is so Charming I
didn't want to watch it contort itself
into something more familiar I wanted to
savor every second of this game that
felt too unique to exist as part of the
Bayonetta series and sure there are
aspects that overlap in portions of the
game that connect Bayonetta Origins to
the mainline Trilogy in very necessary
ways but its focus Direction and The
Confidence it exudes in both never for
change though previous Bayonetta games
also divided their narratives into
chapters the chapters and Bayonetta
Origins are far more literal as the
story is told as if it's a children's
book a tender matronly woman narrates
the tale adding in unique voices for
certain characters such as the
evergrumpy Cheshire while illustrations
fade in and out on the weathered pages
[Music]
even in this form the demon did not seem
happy about being cuddled just folks
still will you the game as a whole has a
Whimsical painterly quality to it that
perfectly suits a sense of wonder and it
uses color and camera angles to create
spectacles that add a bit of grandeur
and Magic to the intimate experience
though the Nintendo switch might not be
able to keep up with its fellow current
gen consoles graphically Bayonetta
Origins is a great example of how
developers can combat that by focusing
on Artistry rather than Fidelity it is
important to note though that the game's
more free-flowing art style looks much
sharper in portable mode however all of
this pills into how sweet and affecting
the Bayonetta Origins narrative is for
years now the games industry has called
for games to Showcase motherhood and
this game is absolutely Platinum game's
triumphant attempt to satiate that need
additionally cereza is every bit as
charismatic as the older version of
herself in this game her lines are
delivered with sincerity youthful joy
and emotion and her moral compass and
strength make her easy to love both
cereza and Cheshire bounce between
cheeky and reluctantly compassionate
with ease and pure adorableness and it
makes for a delightful Dynamic that
evolves into a truly special
relationship whilst some folks who
raised eyes at band at a three-story
might be wary of the direction Bayonetta
origin seems to be going in at its start
hang in there I think you'll be
pleasantly surprised Bayonetta origin
cereza and the lost demon is a testament
to thinking outside the box while I
don't suspect Platinum Games will pivot
to this new style of gameplay and
storytelling in future Bayonetta games
in the same way breath of the wild or
God of War 2018 shift to the direction
of their franchises I cannot help but be
thankful that the studio trusted the
vision of its team enough to create this
experience though with how fantastic
just about every aspect of the game is I
understand why the developer did
[Music]
thank you